Chris you there dan what's happening
brother my bun where are you right now I
am at Longboat Key Florida having a good
time I just got back from a about a 3.2
mile run which I used to be able to do
backwards in my sleep now I feel like
I've got heart palpitations I'm sweating
all over myself and just barely making
it through so there you go you remember
when we used to be athletes brother we
were liked it up with one star oh yeah
that was a long the older I get the
better I was Chris tell me look at this
I even have a light I've been doing so
many of these zoom things now I actually
have something to you can help the cause
a little bit you got any memorabilia
behind you let me see
nope if I go into your house do well do
I know that you played football if you
go into PFF you know that I played
football so obviously we're we're we
started that company on a shoestring
budget and so all of the decorations
thanks my wife Holly were all stuff and
crap and things that she did not want in
her house so she kindly donated the PFF
so all any and all memorabilia that I
have is down there and now it is
literally embarrassing I mean it's like
you know got my my my when I went to
summer basketball camp
I won the lay up contest I got all that
stuff and PFF is pro Football Focus what
was the goal when you started this I
well you know I didn't start it a bunch
of guys in England were actually Neil
Hornsby and the guys are the ones that
actually started it
and I just literally was looking for
help on mine they wanted me to do a
postgame show on NBC and I said well hey
that's a great idea except I never see
any of the games other than no one that
we're doing Sunday night I may you know
have it on in the background but I'm
studying all day trying to get ready for
our game as well so I started looking
around and I find these
sheets and color-coded things that PFF
put out and so I plugged in 2699 and I
say okay buh-bye nice is pretty good
because I'd done a bunch of these games
recently so I type in the little you
know contact us thing I said who the
hell are you guys I figure there's a
bunch of coaches or something like that
and so about three minutes later this
guy Neil Hornsby calls and with this
British accent and he says those new
ones I can't do a British accent it's
the Holmes but you know they're so nice
to meet you Chris and all I can think is
this SOB just hustled me out of twenty
six ninety-nine I'm so out of my mind
mad I can't stand so I said this
couldn't last about 15 seconds so I
start firing off questions to him about
you know linebackers and guards and
kickers and things that no way he's
gonna this Brit knows anything about
right after about five minutes I have
shut up and just started listening this
guy knows way more about football knows
way more about the lead knows way more
about everything than I do and I said
who in the hell are you and they had
this internet band of brothers put
together about 11 of them that was they
just they found American football
interesting started when all the online
stuff started back in the you know in
the early 2000 and the 90s and ice when
they had 11 or 12 teams that were paying
for their services at the time it's just
one of the most incredible stories that
you did you ever hear and now it's you
know all 32 teams and 70-something
college teams and the network's and it's
been pretty fun
PFF recently simulated the 2020 NFL
season said there was 10,000
games or times that they did this over
and over and over what was the big
headline that you took away from this
simulated twenty20 season that I have no
idea what they're doing when they do
that it was you know it really is you
know it's almost about
the gambling part of everything that
goes on and so then you start going
right here's what the over-under is for
all these teams you know this is the you
know the Pittsburgh Steelers at nine and
a half the Detroit Lions at six and a
half and so I started going down the
list and I said all right I don't gamble
but I got as part of me right all of us
would kind of like to you know we all
look at these things and you go I know
more about football than anybody I can
certainly figure this out but I think
the teams that did I would be personally
interested in against those numbers
I like the Steelers that did nine and a
half I mean Ben returns they had through
the twenty seventh ranked offense last
year that's not going to happen again
right team that led in sacks and
takeaways the Detroit Lions at six and a
half with the return of Matthew Stafford
I I think that that's a that's a good
opportunity I don't know that the Green
Bay Packers necessarily got better with
what they did in the draft you know
they've got a backup quarterback now
they've got people but they didn't go
get a receiver they didn't go get a
corner they do get somebody that could
really help the the box at eight points
at seven so Tom Brady gets him to nine
wins what's the last time Tom Brady
didn't get a team to nine wins you know
so he's got we had Chris Godwin in Mike
Evans is the number one and number six
receiver and all the football we know
what their receivers were a season ago
in New England now you add to that mix
the other night I think is a Dallas
Cowboys I love seed Elia I don't know if
you got a chance to see it in your CD
Liam III never scouted a guy in college
football where my comment so I go
through and I watch about an hour on you
know the top 60 or 70 guys and my
comments were always well in this game
he broke this one he broke five tackles
for his 70 yard touchdown in this game
he broke six tackles for a 50 yard
touchdown this game he broke five
tackles for a 50 yard touchdown off the
charts I think he's gonna be a star yeah
I thought he was the best receiver in
the draft but I don't study it like you
do in the scouts do but when you say
break tackles I don't even think they
got close enough to tackle him
I think that they had there needs to be
a new category it's not breaking tackles
it's actually eluding tackles because
that's what CD Lam did in the Texas game
it looks like five guys converge on him
and I don't know if anybody put a pall
on him
I'm is ridiculous you know and the other
thing is I think that we're starting to
see some of these guys so it's a whoever
won the Superbowl right we're all going
to copy down if the 49ers had won they'd
all be doing these outside zones to
tight ends you know all that kind of
stuff but the Kansas City Chiefs one
would say Hill and Kelsey and Watkins
Nicole Hardman and they go out and get
this Edward Slayer who is an
unbelievable guy you talking about
somebody you can't tackle in the open
field as far as a running bang he's
unbelievable but we talked about Tampa
Bay now loading up a receiver the Dallas
Cowboys Bari Cooper Michael gallant with
CD layout Emmanuel Sanders goes the
norrland Saints with Michael Thomas
Stefon Diggs with John Brown and Colby's
I mean you go right down the list
I think the copycat leave right now is
then we're gonna go just load up with
all these unbelievable playmakers
running backs in the league right now
are fairly interchangeable so let's go
get a quarterback let's go get some of
these great wide receivers and let's see
what happens out there but it is turning
into touch football I mean it really is
it's turning into all right let's put
nobody in the backfield and then spread
to sucker out and go throw it around for
you've got the 49ers and the Shanahan
style of play
let's compact it like the Rams like you
saw with the 49ers like you're gonna see
with the Green Bay Packers a little bit
and let's do the outside zone the
bootlegs and and the jet sweeps and
everything off of that he's Cris
Collinsworth NBC Sunday Night Football
color analyst with Al Michaels Michele
Tafoya a couple of questions here we'll
breeze through them
Joe burrow start day one if you're the
Bengals yes
all right way to get the lose right I
mean yeah for a little bit there a
little bit of your hometown team through
I
there's something about Joe burrow that
I have liked from the beginning and I
tried to figure out what it was and I
was watching their Center
getting ready for the draft he's a nice
player I want to put him down at all but
he didn't like clean miss a few times
and passed protection that clearly was
the weakest part of his game
and so Joe Barroso I'm watching them I
was really watching the center but of
course burrows behind him and burrows a
prince ability to just step around some
of these unblocked guys and make a
little move and play you know Tom
Brady's not fast but if you watch Tom
Brady throughout the course of his
career he has a nice little feel for
what's going on in the pocket and can
kind of step around that and the other
part of his game that I really liked was
he reminds me of my guy Troy Aikman
now you know Troy and Troy can be a
little salty at times right like joy
he's never going to have a problem
telling you exactly how he feels about
anything and of course with all the big
personalities and the Dallas Cowboys
back in the day in the day with Jerry
and Jimmy and everything that was going
on Michael it really took that trying to
no-nonsense guy to pull him out of the
pit I mean don't forget tre its first
year in the league when they go one in
15 on the night yeah and so now you've
got a guy so I say throw them in there I
mean let them learn on the job they're
gonna be a little bit better in the
offensive line they had the first-round
pick last year that never played for
them you know they got better receivers
at this point sign t Hague and so I I
mean I think at this point you've got
nothing to lose and when you look in the
league right now Dan what is happening
is we have and we're doing a lot of
study on this right now
Eric Iger a great guy pfff where dr.
Iger is taking a hard look at this thing
at what point do these rookie
quarterbacks on their rookie wage scale
begin to outweigh the greatness of some
of these veteran players so as we get
into you know we've seen rookie
quarterbacks and excuse me going to the
Superbowl almost every year here lately
so right there the cheaper quarterbacks
allow you to have a better team on the
other end of it
so let's see the Patrick mahomes now
breaks into the 50 million dollar dare
abouts category which I think he
deserves honestly I think he's the
future of the NFL in so many different
ways but as you begin to look at it in
the
persons that we're making right now is
as you get into that gap of one player
making that much money as great a player
as he is is that the long-term solution
to winning or is it the Lamar Jackson's
and the Jared Goff's and all these guys
who are on their rookie contracts that
allowed you to have these other players
on the team there really gives you a
best shot to win some game so is that
what New England's doing right now I
don't know but it's gonna be interesting
to watch well that's why I have to look
at cam or not can't I'll get to Cam
Newton dak Prescott situation and say is
he worth this money that I think he's a
good quarterback but do I get to the
point where I say I'd rather try to find
a quarterback that I can have that five
year window for your window with a
salary that like Seattle did you know
Seattle when Russ came in they got a
break and they were able to build that
team Dallas is at the breaking point I
think because you spent all that money
on everybody and now dak comes in and
reportedly turned down five for 175
at what point do you go in it's exactly
the point exactly what we're studying
right now and we I'm saying we I'm just
gonna throw out Eren Yeager's name
because it's really yeah he's the
mathematician but but that is exactly
the line and when we tried to break it
down with just quarterbacks right the
numbers came out very clear that if the
rookie wage fails gave you a great
advantage but the clearer picture of
what was really going on was the
totality of everything within it within
the league whether it was you had to add
up the quarterback and the rum and the
wide receivers and the offense of mind
and the tight end we sort of left the
running backs out for now and we'll
explain all that later but when you you
begin to add up all of those categories
they sort of came out pretty close right
they were like in the you know like
Baltimore had a great advantage so
Baltimore with Lamar Jackson drafted
late in the first round had to pay very
little tip for their quarterback
position so they can load up they can
sign clay as Campbell this offseason
they could do some different things so
they were mourned that the
thirty-five million something like that
maybe even low 30s but then most of the
teams that had a quarterback were up in
the fifty to fifty five million dollar
range so that means now if you come in
and you're gonna sign Patrick mahomes
for forty five fifty million dollars
right that scale is now going to slide
up so high what are you going to do
right now they've been able to sign two
tackles on the Kansas City Chiefs they
can play right they have more wide
receivers than they know what to do that
they have Kelsey that is you know making
good money Chris Jones you got to make a
decision on on the other side of the
ball so at some point you don't get to
say I'm just gonna pay this guy you've
got to say I'm gonna pay this guy and
it's gonna cost me this guy this guy
this guy in this guy and that's the
decision is dec now it works as long as
you have a Russell Wilson a Drew Brees
Aaron Rodgers yes somebody of that
caliber and the question for the Dallas
Cowboys very clearly now does dak fit in
that category yes or no would you signed
act Prescott to that money you know I
think playing quarterback to the Cowboys
is a unique position it takes a special
person it takes a big personality they
can handle the sort of the weight of
everything that comes with it including
Jerry is the owner including all the the
media attention including playing on
prime time all the time and I think dak
is that unique leader and I honestly he
made a huge jump in my mind last year I
think he handles the pressure
I think he's plenty mobile enough in
this league that I think is really
making a bold move in that direction I
don't think the quarterback position
will look anything like what we were
used to it ten years ago 20 years ago
pretty soon here
I think he's plenty mobile enough he's a
really smart guy he can handle it I
would pay him in about the range where
they're talking about now but if it
starts getting up closer to the 40
million or whatever plus I'd have a
problem just based on the math that
we're doing right now where's the ideal
place for Camden Lynn oh my gosh well
the easy answer is new
and right I mean that's that's where you
look at cam and I think that cam cams a
unique personality you mean he just is
right he likes the clothes he likes the
flash he's a he's an interesting
character to talk with I always thought
that a place like New England where it
just forces you to focus like if I if I
wanted to play somewhere you know I
played for Forrest Gregg my first couple
years in the league didn't talk about
being able to focus that guy if he was
coming down the hallway towards me I'd
I'd turned around went upstream I just
was I did I never he wanted to pass him
in the hallway and I think Belichick
allows you to have that kind of focus I
think he needs to extend his game just a
little bit I don't think he has the
physical tools that do it but it'll take
a lot of discipline I'll take some
humility to to be able to sharpen the
some of his skills especially now in
light of the injury so if I had to say I
think that would be the interesting spot
that behind stem I'll leave you with
this how does it go wrong for Tom Brady
in Tampa I don't think it does I'll be
perfectly honest Lee I really like what
they what they have go on there but
mostly because I think Tom Brady was
handed a shorter deck with the wide
receiver position for the last few years
here and now he's got players there
obviously injury could come about but I
feel like the only thing that could
maybe be a bit of a problem especially
now with Gronk on the team in in the
short season right I mean we've done I
don't know how Carolina's gonna put a
football team together new coach new
quarterback new coordinators and no time
to be together so maybe if they get off
to a slow start in Tampa because they
haven't had that practice time that
they're used to having and it's a tough
division in New Orleans gets the better
of them maybe that's how it happens but
I I really am excited to watch Tampa
this year I just really I think that
that entire city is so
to be a buzz I don't think Tom Brady has
lost anything
I shouldn't say hasn't lost anything of
course he's lost something but I really
feel like that they have the ability to
come right out and play great football
and I do think he has two good years at
him and Bruce Arians as long as those
two can figure out a common offense
where it's not Tom Brady and Gronk go
and listen we don't have time Bruce to
put in everything this is what I know
how to run I'm going to teach my guys
how to do it and somehow Bruce or Byron
Leftwich or somebody that causes a
problem but I just don't see that
happening I really don't
good stuff Chris my best of Holly and
thanks for joining us good luck with the
pro Football Focus Thank You Pat good
talking to you Dan that's Cris
Collinsworth